PAUL LEWIS: Are you enjoying the
latest season of HTTP 203, sir?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I am.
Because unlike the last
season, we were in America,
and we were having
a little adventure.
We went to a billiard hall,
we went to the seaside.
PAUL LEWIS: We went
on roller coasters,
which is always a good thing.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: What
did we talk about?
We talked about ES6.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
We talked about
maintainable code.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We've got an
episode on HTTP2 coming up.
That's cool.
PAUL LEWIS: That's
going to be exciting.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
One of the things
I've been enjoying
the most is seeing
the various levels
of sunburn that I
have throughout the
various episodes.
PAUL LEWIS: It's like
a game, because I
can't remember the order
that we filmed them in.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Because
it's not the order
we've been showing them in.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
Why would we do that?
So instead, it's like, yeah,
oh, that's an 8 out of 10
for Jake on the sunburn-o-meter.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But
we do have a problem.
Because previously, our
videos have been on the Google
Developers YouTube channel.
But we're now moving everything
onto the new Chrome Developers
channel.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes, we are.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
we need to find a way
to tell the audience that,
but we don't acknowledge
the audience in our show.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
There's a fourth wall
that we never, ever break.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
how are we going
to tell everyone to subscribe to
the Chrome Developers channel?
[MUSIC PLAYING]